apenas unos días después de que el
kremlin anunciara oficialmente la
anexión de la región de zaporilla el
jefe de la Hoya Rafael grossi se dirigió
a quieep para hablar sobre la seguridad
de la planta nuclear y dijo que el
organismo de la ONU todavía considera
que la central es una institución
ucraniana
para nosotros es obvio que al tratarse
de una instalación ucraniana la
propiedad es de energuatón
en cuanto a los cambios contractuales
que puedan producirse como resultado del
anuncio es algo que tendré que discutir
en Rusia en los próximos días
las tensiones en torno a la central se
han agudizado tras que el presidente
Vladimir Putin la decretara como
propiedad rusa ya que zaporiya es una de
las cuatro regiones anexionadas
ilegalmente por el kremlin el presidente
ucraniano borodimir zelenski acusa a
Rusia de chantaje para quedarse con la
instalación
la toma de nuestra central nuclear de
zaporilla ya es un chantaje por las
conversaciones por la presión sobre
Europa y sobre Ucrania esto ya es un
chantaje nuclear porque ahora la planta
está cerrada
desde la invasión
mutuamente por los bombardeos en los
pueblos cercanos a la central que hacen
temer una catástrofe nuclear